[Music]
in the last year North Korea has been
launching a lot of missiles
they're all just tests but they're meant
to send a message North Korea is armed
and dangerous they've demonstrated
missiles that can destroy Seoul and
Tokyo hit US bases in the Pacific and
now one that can reach Alaska have
confirmed that overnight North Korea
launched an intercontinental ballistic
missile ICBM capable of reaching Alaska
Kim jong-un called it a gift to the
Trump administration this is the end
goal or at least towards the end goal
for North Korea it's called the WA song
14 it's the newest member of North
Korea's Arsenal and their first working
intercontinental ballistic missile or
ICBM it's the kind of thing that the US
and Russia have thousands of and had
used as a threat against each other
during the Cold War old at the ready
never less than a thousand miles north
Korea has been working on one of its own
for a while and then now appear to have
won the North Koreans have had nuclear
bombs since 2006 and they could
certainly attack their neighbors but
they've had no real way to deliver them
to a distant target they could try and
drop one from an airplane but it would
be likely shot down well before getting
to the target the most effective way to
use a nuclear bomb is to attach it to a
missile different delivery systems
determine how far the target can be
North Korea already has a huge arsenal
of short and medium-range missiles but
it didn't have a working ICBM which can
hit a target up to 15,000 kilometers
away because it's actually multiple
missiles in one stacked on top of each
other each missile is used one by one to
push the warhead into space then once
it's over a target this final section
re-enters the atmosphere and detonates
this is a very hard thing to engineer
and tests of a previous long-range
missile the type of dong 2 failed
repeatedly but on July 4th 2017 North
Korea successfully tested an ICBM called
it was song 14 it reached a distance of
about nine hundred and thirty kilometers
flew for nearly 40 minutes and
successfully re-entered splashing down
in the Sea of Japan this is a major
milestone for North Korea analysts
calculate that if North Korea wanted to
use those song 14 in a real attack they
would launch it at a lower angle giving
it a range of more than 5,500 kilometers
putting Alaska well in range but this
still doesn't mean North Korea can nuke
Alaska today the Pentagon says that
North Koreans cannot fit a nuclear bomb
on the WA song 14 and have it reliably
detonate see this is a relatively small
ICBM meaning it can't carry a very heavy
nuclear bomb in order for it to make it
to Alaska the North Koreans would have
to figure out how to miniaturize the
bomb and there's no evidence the North
Koreans can do this yet but that was all
14 test shows at North Korea's rapidly
improving its ICBM technology and then
it's determined to build one no matter
who tries to stop them so this raises
the question why is North Korea so dead
set on building an ICBM the North
Koreans first got nuclear technology in
the 1950s when their Ally the Soviet
Union helped them build nuclear reactors
for energy at the same time they were
protected from their enemies South Korea
in the US by the massive nuclear arsenal
of the Soviet Union but in 1991 when the
Soviet Union collapsed that protection
went away so North Korean dictator Kim
Jong ill matters into his own hands and
started using the nuclear reactors to
make weapons the US didn't want an
aggressive rogue state to have nuclear
weapons
so three consecutive US presidents all
tried different tactics to get North
Korea to stop Clinton negotiated Bush
suspended negotiations and threatened
them and Obama simply tried to wait
North Korea out but every single plan
failed to stop the nuclear program and
there's a reason for that see the Kim
dynasty believes their only option for
security is to have proven nuclear
capabilities they saw the u.s. invade
Iraq and topple Saddam Hussein because
they thought he might have nukes they
also saw a Libyan dictator Muammar
Gadhafi negotiate with the US and give
up his nuclear program only to be killed
by us back rebels the Kim dynasty is
determined not
next so they've gone on to build an
arsenal of missiles for their nuclear
bombs the Nodong is functional today and
has a range of 1,500 kilometers and
North Korea's Scud missiles are highly
effective within a thousand kilometers
this puts North Korea's main enemies
South Korea and Japan within range as
well as the 62,000 US troops stationed
there in fact North Korea wants to make
that loud and clear and it does so by
successfully testing these short-range
missiles a lot the tests provide a
chance for them to improve their
missiles but more importantly they send
a political message South Korea and
Japan wouldn't attack North Korea
because they've seen the missiles that
could devastate some of their largest
cities also they don't have nuclear
weapons of their own so what's keeping
North Korea from attacking its enemies
the USS which has promised to protect
South Korea and Japan with the largest
ICBM Arsenal in the world this puts
North Korea at a disadvantage it knows
the u.s. can obliterate it but it can
reach the u.s. just yet this is why the
u.s. can safely cut off North Korean
Trade and enact other punishments and
this brings us back to why North Korea
has been trying so hard to build an ICBM
it's what they need to tip the scales in
their favor right now North Korea can
only attack US allies but if it can
successfully test any of these ICBMs it
would be the same as telling the us if
you knew Gus will nuke you if the u.s.
knows North Korea can target an American
city it'll be less likely to come to the
aid of South Korea or Japan this would
effectively break up the alliance that's
designed to keep North Korea in check
but the implications of this would go
far beyond the Korean Peninsula suddenly
in charge of their own protection South
Korea and Japan would potentially
develop nuclear weapons of their own
something Donald Trump once said he
would be fine with this would trigger a
process called nuclear proliferation and
it's exactly what the US has been trying
to prevent since the Cold War right now
there are nine countries with nuclear
weapons of their own while 190 maintain
a non-nuclear status because of the
non-proliferation treaty but the success
of a North Korean ICBM could change that
if South Korea and Japan started looking
to change their nuclear status it could
encourage other countries to do the same
so experts are urging the u.s. to take
action now while it still can President
Trump is pressing China to help see
China continues to trade and have a dip
relationship with North Korea
essentially keeping the regime alive so
if Trump can get China to leverage or
cut off that support North Korea might
not have enough resources to keep
pursuing an ICBM but for now as North
Korea continues to test and parade
missiles tensions continue to rise three
u.s. presidents have said they'd prevent
the north from building better nukes and
missiles three u.s. presidents have
failed at least for now it looks like
Donald Trump will be the fourth
you